we had families we had the many faces of
Hanna and we had a plethora of red flags
everybody I just be completely yourself
right be real this is your Bachelorette
recap grab your glasses it's time for
roses and rose eh hi everybody it's me
Lauren Zima is this our red rose blanket
or a big old red flag
oh it's hometowns what an episode you
guys it's hometowns and today I actually
don't have Rosie I have Chardonnay why
because I drink Chardonnay with my
mother and this episode made me think of
my mother and this episode made me think
of my family because they were all
thinking of their families and you guys
I cried multiple times my grandparents
you know but like I've loved you too I
was emotional everybody I mean I don't
usually cry watching this Jo but I cried
a lot watching this show and I know I
said last week that it was the first
time I'd ever cried watching Hannah
break up with Mike and some of you
pointed out that actually I had cried
once before when Rachel and Peter broke
up and that's a good point I did cry
that and now I cried a lot
what's wrong with me I don't like this
okay moving on what did you guys think
overall good episode of hometowns I
liked it I liked it through my tears
okay so first we have Peter Weber of
Westlake Village California and Hannah
says that this is down the street from
the mansion
down the street frozen eaten
interestingly though we don't start
anywhere near the mansion we're in a
field of days I don't know why they
started this ear Peters like you're in
my home town right now and Hannah's like
I love it
this field so that's my baby so Peter
wants Seema to see his baby and it is
his car because Peter loves all modes of
transportation the fastest thing the
hometown dates were really on point
about the guys
things weren't sale like Peters the
transportation guy and Jed's the guitar
guy and Luke's the Christian guy and
Tyler's the man who stands up for women
where do you want to wind up Tyler is
also this shirtless guy let's be honest
so they're in Peters car and Hannah
finds a condom Peter Scott and I love
this because I love when they break the
fourth wall Peter's like oh my god no
don't put that on camera like a gay on
the cameras for the show but guess what
Peter we saw it and you know Peters like
I'm a safe guy whether I'm flying or
another f-word and I don't want to shock
anyone but pilot Pete takes Hannah
flying drink for every mode of
transportation Hannah's in in this
episode she literally goes by air by
land and by sea okay
don't drink every time Peter and Hannah
say it's so cool to do what they're
doing
[Music]
is it that cool it's fine do not drink
every time Peter does what has become
his signature howl it started last week
after Hannah gave him the rose on the
group date with Jared and Luke and now
we're continuing it yes then our
theatres family and oh my gosh they are
so cute if you guys had to pick a
favorite family from the hometown dates
who are you picking I got to say I loved
Peters his mom and dad were both so
sweet they both made me cry and him and
his little brother were dressed exactly
the thing it was so cute my grandparents
you know but I could've loved you too
and drink for every time Peter was
really emotive about his strong feelings
for Hannah this episode the way I've
been with her no one's ever made me feel
he's saying he's never felt this way
before but I have not felt like this
truly having he's never felt this
strongly before I've never felt this
he's never brought a girl home when we
felt this strongly before like I've
never brought someone home that I felt
so strongly for I'm a second man now in
the past we learned Peter speaks Spanish
and now we're sort of learning why
though I still wish they'd explained it
more I think the implication here is
that Peters Cuban they talk about Cuban
food but then they do a German prayer
which I guess is Weber and they howl
this is a vocal family I love it it's
fun great I'm just very emotional right
now and then Peters sweet mom is talking
to Hannah and I'm crying and then Peter
says he thinks he's not my person I
don't and I'm crying why and then Peters
dad is crying and I'm sobbing
[Music]
I'm sorry was crying was this just me
his dad just looks so like a dad like
it's such a dad Erica I was just crying
I
I am definitely there I don't like I'm
falling very crazy right now and Peter
says he's in love with Hannah
so here we go it's getting real everyone
drink every time somebody says love I
love it
you think she's in love with you he said
I love you to her yet you guys love you
are definitely in love with Hannah I'll
be able to say I love you you know I do
I started actually falling in love with
her what do you think has the realest
truest deepest feelings for Hannah right
now we are currently in Jupiter Florida
about to have my hometown with Hannah
brown
grab your swimsuits grab your sunscreen
forget your shirt it's time for Tyler C
prep to be scandal-free it's Tyler C
Chad's not the only one who can make up
songs this episode so we are in Jupiter
Florida with Tyler this might be my
favorite hometown date ever
huh I'm gonna tell you why a lot of
important points ahead I will make my
case it's beautiful so beautiful well
you're out sign it right now but it's
beautiful
so Tyler always has a beautiful
compliment for Hannah right he'll say
something like we're here in my hometown
which is beautiful but you're out
shining it he's always given Hannah a
one-up compliment which you know what I
like it's a signature move
and I'm in for it Oh was that a windmill
no just to lighthouse
ha ha ha we got to keep our eyes open
thank you point to Tyler's hair looks
great number three we're going on a boat
the best way to explore Jupiter is by
bow I love boats
wrap your swimsuits grab your sunscreen
or we're getting not a boat we have
Tyler see you don't need
Tyler T you just need a Tyler C and
don't drink every time the state Hannah
made some kind of illusion to Tyler's
path everything concerns for me that
Tyler's ready for like next steps in a
relationship I will say that I wish we
just address this throughout the date
with Tyler there are these implications
I think that he might have been a player
see you know seeing it completely
changed I could legitimately see my
brother getting engaged
if so honestly no judgement you're in
your early 20s whatever as long as you
treat people well on an individual basis
you don't have to be locked into a
serious relationship but did you guys
feel like they were trying to say Tyler
you've been a player without saying it
let me know in the comments below
I think he's super hot and we are
soaking in the Sun and you're swimming
in the water
and enjoying this beautiful weather with
a beautiful girl oh and we are having
margaritas ever oh we love Jupiter
Florida because after all it's already
given us we then take a turn and there's
live music and red alert everybody red
alert
shirtless dancing Tyler C catches Hannah
as she jumps into his arms
I know we're gonna pray with Luke later
but I need a prayer right now send me up
from Jesus give me some love from the
Lord I needed to get through this
fabulous moment I thought that it was
enough when he lifted her onto the horse
but then he shirtless catches her midair
please have you ever seen your dad no I
haven't seen him since I left I had kind
of forgotten that Tyler's dad was really
sick right before he left so we're going
to see Tyler reunite with his father who
had been very ill and I am bracing
myself for more tears Tyler and his dad
are hugging and I am crying thank you
buddy you look great man he's like hi
pops
and he says back I love you buddy -
buddy love you man any more wine for all
these tears that's not a good thing to
say about love
Tyler's I want to let many people he
caused all mm-hmm Tyler's dad talked to
Hannah about how Tyler has a hard time
getting close to people I wanted to know
the why there give us more on that
what is Tyler's trauma that's a horrible
ask but I do want to know sorry
and as if Tyler C hadn't given us enough
he then changes the very structure of
this show Hannah is going to get in the
car to leave and most people say I don't
want you to go but Tyler says I'm gonna
go watch I think I'd leave you here
mm-hmm but I'm not okay
he's getting in that car because he's
gonna be by her side or at the very
least kind of beautifully on top of her
and a cute make out sort of the way and
it was wonderful and Tyler's honest
about his feelings he says one day I'll
be able to say I love you you know and I
do believe that I'll be able to say a
hundred percent behind it he says he
wants to say he loves Hannah he feels
he's on that path but he doesn't want to
say it just yet
okay being real I get it then we have
Luke P in Gainesville G for Georgia
how'd you get excited sort of this like
P date isn't it like when you guys were
about to watch the Luke P date were you
excited to see Anna Mina's family and
stuff on the bright side Hanna is in
another cute colorful leather jacket and
this dates about the bright sides isn't
it because we've had so many dark times
with Luke P and we got some bright sides
here we did which still isn't saying
much now I want you to get to know me
better
okay so I figured reduce something yeah
I do a weekly basis so drink every time
one of the guys is on brand this episode
Luke's activity with Hanna is to go to
Sunday schools yeah every Sunday before
church we have a Sunday school isn't
even Sunday that's a question I had no
way to know oh I was chasing sex and
drink every time we hear Luke say
something he said before this date
because he gets up to tell his story
again and talks about chasing sex and I
was entangled and caught up in sin man
tells that shower story I remember
getting in the shower I mean drink every
time Luke says I remember I remember
getting in the shower I remember feeling
like I had all this weight on me and I
remembered
I remember and I remember seeing like a
hole open up but Luke we're done
remembering in fact we'd like to forget
we don't want to remember we want to
reinvent we don't want to remember we
want to reconfigure Luke let go we don't
want to remember we want to reevaluate
does he know what's another all either
the red or red flags that's all we've
gotten with Luke all season long but
Hanna said she's seen the good and loop
through all the drama so we are powering
through anything that you look at to be
negative in your life I want you to know
that like God is gonna use that for a
positive but on the bright side Luke
says one good thing he advises that
every negative you have in your life God
is gonna use that for positive and I I
agree with that I do see the positive
where is it
I see it and it I want to see it okay so
here's the real deal it's just evident
how
whereas hi talks right side Lucas
surrounded by what I'm calling Luke's
army they are his family and friends and
they are telling Hanna he's such a great
guy he makes friends with everyone
literally making everybody around they
are praying over him they are supporting
him they're endorsing I feel like
sparingly people who love Him really
brings him back to like who he is and my
question was why because this is not the
Luke we've seen why do you guys think
that the Luke on the Bachelorette is so
different from the Luke these people no
my guess is that Luke is someone who can
thrive in his environment in his world
with the rules that he plays by but when
Luke is in an environment unfamiliar to
him with people of different backgrounds
and ideas and choices he doesn't do well
because he disagrees and when he
disagrees he shames let me know in the
comments below
way down deep below and the darkness and
I want to applaud Hannah for being
honest with Luke's family she said we've
had some issues I mean it was just like
constant me trying to get him to talk
about everything and we've had some
disagreements I've called him out to
hear the stories and stuff that happened
I mean that's not like my son Luke's
brother says that Luke is a man who will
be humbled and then once he realizes it
nice he's like okay that wasn't cool
like you will see the most humble guy
and I want a drink for every time
Hannah's face says something this
episode because Hannah's face is like
humble is he
and Luke's dad says that it's clear that
Hanna wants to be the one for Luke not
only could she be the one she wants to
be the one she's like you know I know
that you've probably I have put you
through a struggle Luke says some good
stuff to Hanna he tells her that he's
put her through a struggle have any
sorry I'm sure and this is one of the
only times we've heard Luke truly
flat-out owned his behavior on the show
so okay I'm not gonna drink for it I'll
just
I can't even raise my glass for it I'll
just look at my wine for it I'm thinking
about what I want the future to be I
wanted to be better and there's still a
lot that I have to show him Luke says
but Hanna is his future wife that I am
looking at my future wife and Luke says
that he loves her I can tell you that I
do love you and they have a really
beautiful makeout session and I get my
emotional self is back I don't know why
but I was getting I there I wasn't
crying I wasn't crying but I was getting
like some goose bumps trying it I mean
they do have chemistry the chemistry is
there and I think it's kept Hannah
holding on isn't it all those red flags
Hannah even says we had a good day he
had a good day all day all day that's a
bum deal you know you don't want to be
celebrated he had one good day
to make it crystal and then oh this is
ominous she says and I quote but don't
screw up
hurt you or I'll freakin hurt you but we
know it's going knowing she's had sex
and Jesus still loves her in a windmill
twice yeah I have feeling like I've
fallen in love with him I'm falling in
love with him now what is interesting
you guys is Luke tells Hannah that he
loves her but he hasn't even told Luke
she's falling in love with him as of
even the end of this episode
she has only said that to Jed
interesting do you think it matters that
Hannah has only said she's falling in
love to Chet I might make us cry later
so grab your tissues why did that one
sticker there's something on it gross
okay then we have Jed Wyatt in Knoxville
Tennessee and what are we gonna see him
playing the guitar you know what's
coming it's he always has something in
his pocket for me panna says Jed always
has something in his pocket for her like
what the guitar picks and yep there we
are at the recording studio didn't take
long mm-hmm we're just gonna try to tell
our story and we'll make a melody and
we're writing a song and Wow Hannah says
that she thanks the Lord for Jeb thank
you earn so much
it's a great day here in Tennessee
Hanna's faith she told me is very
important to her and for her to say that
she thanks the Lord for shed a
significant to me what do you guys think
is Jed still the contract I felt he was
the front-runner after last week's
episode and I still think his and again
let's drink for a significant face from
Hannah there recording the song in
Hannah's face when she kissed Jed with
those headphones on I thought it was
telling
she just looks at him like she loves him
you know I think so then we go to Jed's
family and Jed says he's gonna rip a
cheers I'm gonna rip a chairs what does
that mean so many new phrases on this
season of The Bachelorette I'm gonna
fall in love for you and Ripa Cheers
don't you say you're gonna rip up fight
because if you were dripping tears
before I don't know what it means but we
did it and a cheers to the persons I am
starting to love oh and then Jed invents
another new phrase he says he is
starting to love I'm starting to love
and when we always say I'm falling for
you but now we're starting to love and
by the way just 30 seconds ago you told
her you were in love with her so are you
starting to be or are you are you in are
you out I am starting to awesome we're
yeah Jed I got a lot of questions when
you stick to your truth it's beneficial
to everybody just as we've been doing
with Jed the past few episodes we are
looking at Jed's family through the lens
of what we have heard about him and his
alleged ex-girlfriend with whom he went
on the show allegedly still dating and
he allegedly told her he was going to
continue dating her once he was off the
show and I interviewed this woman Haley
and what she told me is that Jed's mom
kind of knew that he was going on the
show just for his career and and so I'm
just looking at this all through this
lens it's a little surprising you know
because I still don't have my head
around all this
Jed's dad says that things are a little
surprising and that he still doesn't
have his head around all of it he was
crazy and what is it is the itch that he
didn't expect his son who he thought was
going on the show for his career to come
back saying he was in love with this
woman especially when he thought that
his son had a different girlfriend who
he was allegedly in love with question
mark I don't know so you know with Jed
our red flag has been raised
and it's getting higher each week isn't
it it's all the way up at full mast it's
really waving in the wind do you feel
like Jed would be at a point in his life
where he would be ready for that way
before taking the relationships out of
it Jed's mom says that music is Jed's
heart-and-soul try to create time and
space to do his music it's his heart and
it's his soul I'm very protective over
Jack then oh my god Jed's sister is
savage she says she's not sure if it's a
good idea for Chet for Anna and honestly
like him potentially falling in love
with you I'm like I'm not sure that it's
a good thing
hey girls be combined
I appreciate it that's what ham is all
about Judds mom is saying that this
doesn't feel realistic it doesn't all
feel very realistic to me but you know
you're the one living it and Red's
trying to say it's real this is a grill
emotions she's looking sort of surprised
and I'm really reading into this as to
whether she's possibly talking about his
feelings being real because Jed's ex
said that she sent jet off to go on the
show not thinking it was a real show so
does Jed's mom think that Jed's feelings
are real I think this is crazy
Oh like she asked me upstairs if I
thought prior to this would she be ready
to be engaged
I said no Ripa cheers everybody to this
skin mess
[Music]
tonight did not go like I expected it
would go I did not get in the validation
that I thought I would get the whole
vibe of Jed's visit was downer and
Hannah said that and then at the end
shed it was like it could have gone
better such a beautiful day everything
just worked out it's like getting could
overjet 90% and it's time for the rose
ceremony it feels like a very impossible
situation with like having feelings for
multiple men um Hannah doesn't know what
she's going to do and I don't either did
you guys have any idea how this rose
ceremony would end I felt as though we
have gotten red flags from Luke all
season right I mean Luke is like a bag
of red flags
he's like a banner of red flags he's
like running the factory where the red
flags are made and then we've got jet
and Jed on camera has been swimming
right along all season long if we hadn't
heard what we'd heard about jet up until
this point we would have thought he was
quite sweet and this was the first red
flag that we've had from Jed I mean per
her relationship with Luke we know that
Hannah is okay with ignoring a red flag
or two you know so I didn't know it was
gonna happen I'm not thinking she's
gonna send Jett home he's the only
person she said she's falling in love
with and she still seems to have such a
strong connection to Luke and Tyler's
not done a thing wrong nor has Peter so
what - okay I mean if those that's
disgusting
this behavior Peter
so Peter gets the first rose I don't
know if I saw their coming I don't know
if you think any more and then Tyler
gets a rose well I'm happy about that
and now it's Jed versus Luke it's a bag
of red flags versus one big red flag and
the flags are waving in the wind
Anna's talking to Chris and says she has
four great men hmm
and she needs more time yes because Luke
took up a lot of it I can't make a
decision I don't know what to do and we
cut back to the guys and they say it'll
be baloney if Jed doesn't get a rose
it'll be complete baloney if you don't
get a rose I can't believe we're talking
about Bologna again how do you compare
Apple storage is securely to Cana what
like you can't Hannah tells Chris that
she can't compare the fruit you know one
guy's grapefruit one guy's a star fruit
one guy's a kumquat and one guy's a
jicama
and sometimes there's a delicious snack
but it's unhealthy and sometimes there's
a nutritious snack but it's boring and
sometimes you have a perfect snack the
banana takes a little bit of work you
got to peel back the layers but inside
it's amazing you know what maybe we want
to
have it twice I hate myself for doing
that snacks on snacks on snacks and then
Chris Harrison comes in and gives Hanna
the roses she asked for you know you
might need one rose and then you might
need another rose so Luke gets a rose
and Jed gets the rose and everybody's go
into the van aziz soo weeds gonna get
yours girl i applaud you
now Hanna's changing the structure of
the show and it's brilliant way - hey
what do you guys think were you
surprised that Hanna kept all four guys
I got a rose but to be honest it doesn't
feel like I got a rose at all but then I
was sort of surprised Jed is all mad
about the Rose situation he doesn't like
that he and Luke both got roses he says
what the f is going on she's been a
constant talks him through every bit of
this what I will say is that jet is
talking about Luke being a toxin on this
journey on this experience on camera and
that's true where Jed has been a toxin
is off-camera
through every bit of this Luke has been
a toxin Jed on the other hand through
every bit of this has been a guitar
player
okay next week on The Bachelorette and
then we have a trailer and you know what
I'm glad that Hanna kept Luke because
it's giving us this conversation my
husband would never say what you said to
me this I've had sex of Jesus still
loves me mama Jesus still loves me that
we've been waiting all season for this
altercation which we know needs to the
windmill reveal I love
now does this look like a window it's
hard to overstate oh wait now easier to
get a flag and we here here - singing
about the fantasy suites and I love that
because I can relate the fantasies away
ultimately you guys a really good
episode obviously I cried a ton yeah and
here's a big question
is it Peter with humor chemistry is a 10
out of 10 is it Jed with whom she is
falling in love is it Tyler who looks
like a shirtless is it look it's not
there's no way it's Luke we know it's
not Luke so the other three options are
available a B or Tyler C let me know in
the comments below I love you guys so
much thank you beyond for watching roses
and Rosie I am on Cameo if you would
like a message from me I adore you
because none of you give me red flags
let's finish our wine because Hanna
needs it
[Music]
Wow JC and I didn't know this but we're
it kind of matched today look it's like
when all the guys forties we're all
wearing blue house C's
shirts and you know what I would like
for you to find the right match JC a
single and available
my oh my got it actually starting to cry
again right now I'm not joking back in
my ice saltwater